Neil, our technician suddenly got inspiration from his own physics teacher.
He's devised a machine which will allow him to put a high current
through a piece of thin wire. And as he turns the knob,
the current goes up and up and up until the wire fails. Ready when you,
after this one. So we started with copper.
What happens is that as you put the current through the copper,
it gets hotter and hotter and hotter. And in this case,
copper melts before it catches fire.
So suddenly you see the wire sinking down and down
and down, and eventually it breaks. And as it breaks,
there is a flash as the cup of vaporizes.
And you may remember that copper gives a nice green color in the vapor.
So you see very quick flash to bring light.
So Neo has a great ambition to try and burn aluminum.
So he got a piece of aluminum wire and heated it up,
but like copper Allen mini melts before it catches fire
in the air. So suddenly it starts cycling,
cycling, cycling, and after a little bit it breaks.
Yes.
Neil was a bit disappointed, nothing burned.
So we tried magnesium didn't have magnesium wire.
So we tried magnesium ribbon. That's relatively flat material.
And as you heat that because the heated metal
expands,
the magnesium started arching upwards,
and then suddenly it drew.
Okay.
But as probably many of you know, that once you've set fire to magnesium,
it keeps burning.
So the whole lot burnt away with clouds of white
smoke, which essentially is finely divided. Magnesium oxide.
Magnesium is a metal that once you light it,
it generates so much heat that the burning becomes
self-sustaining.
It's probably because the metal doesn't conduct away the heat very much from the
area that's burning, whereas aluminium and copper,
if you set it on fire and remove the source of heat,
it quickly goes out. Probably the metal just cools down to false.
[Inaudible].
Neil suddenly remembered he had some special way,
or he took Brady to his special store. He calls it the dark hole.
Doesn't want me going there?
I might start taking things from it in the dark hole.
What's the remains of a superconducting magnets,
very powerful magnet that gets used in an instrument some years ago,
the magnet consists of a coil and Neil cutoff,
a piece of this alloy,
the wire that's used for this magnets has to be insulated.
Otherwise it would short circuit and it's insulated with Val niche.
So as it heats up,
there's a bit of smoking as the varnish vaporizer,
Slightly disappointingly. It behaves much the same as the other metal.
Sykes flashes and breaks
necks.
Neil produced a piece of tungsten wire tungsten wire is what's used in
old fashioned light bulbs. It was really interesting as you heat it up,
it gets hotter and hotter.
Tungsten has the highest melting point of any of the metals that we used,
and it starts to burn doesn't melt at all
and just gets thinner and thinner and thinner until it fails.
He ended up with quite a terrifying looking spike of
really narrow tungsten.
So professor, this did fire quite quickly, but light bulbs don't fail quickly.
Ideally.
What's the difference between this and a light bulb?
The difference from the light bulb is that in the light bulb,
the tungsten is not as hot as at the end of Neil's
experiment.
And of course the bulb itself is filled with argon gas rather
than with air Neil.
And I were both really quite fascinated by this very narrow spike that is
made.
And I think it just because one part of the wire must've started
getting thinner than the rest and therefore hotter and therefore preferentially,
the hottest part will have burned. Fastest Brady really wanted to do gold.
Neil was a bit reticent. Gold is expensive.
So he puts a glass dish underneath.
Now I must say that gold was probably the most disappointing of the mall
because it's heated up it melted. It broke
it didn't give a really very convincing flash gold.
Doesn't have a beautiful green color like copper, but Brady was satisfied.
Uh, Neil didn't lose any gold.
I think the most exciting metal,
and this was a real surprise with molybdenum.
When we heated up molybdenum,
even when I was watching the camera from the distance,
there seem to be some sort of pulsating on the picture.
And when we looked at the metal afterwards,
it was extraordinary because instead of having a smooth
wire,
there were little blobs of molybdenum metal all the way along the
wire and these blobs were really quite evenly
spaced.
[Inaudible].
No, it turns out that this phenomenon has been seen in exploding wires
using very high-speed cameras. I think it's unusual. I,
and none of my colleagues had seen anything like this before. Now.
You probably,
or some of you who are specialists in this area probably have some really good
explanation of why this happened.
I think what happened is that the molybdenum metal began to
melt on the surface of the wire.
So you mentioned the wire covered with a thin layer of liquid.
And because liquid has surface tension,
this is why liquid forms drops.
I think that the liquid separated into little drops
because the surface tension pulled it together.
And so you get what would normally be little drops
of liquid, but they solidified.
So we've somehow got them fossilized along this wire,
all my colleagues that I've shown these bits of wire to have got really excited.
It's really surprising that you can get such an even spacing.
I did a bit of research on this phenomenon and I came across a word
I'd never heard before called under Lloyds until Lloyd is the word that
mathematicians use to describe this sort of object.
I would be very interested to hear from any of you who has a really good
explanation of what's happened.
Neil thinks that the spacing might be related to the frequency of
the mains.
So he's keen to try and use direct current rather than alternating current
and see whether we get the same effect. I think there'll be no difference.
I had the, that we should turn the operators through 90 degrees.
So the wire is vertical and it would be much more difficult for it to sag.
And what we found was indeed it didn't sag so
much, at least until it broke.
And we got a much better shot of the flash of
green light as the cup of vaporized,
there was still slight bending, but it was much less than before,
just as we were packing up,
I persuaded Neil to make a coil of copper.
We put this coil vertically.
My idea was that the COI would be floppier than the straight piece of wire.
So it might sink more,
but then it collapsed quite spectacularly once it did.
[Inaudible].
Chemically.
What was interesting to me was that if you looked at the bit that was broken,
you could see the black copper to oxide on the surface of the
copper showing that there was at least some reaction with oxygen,
but very much less than saying the burning magnesium.
I was really grateful to Neil because he devised a demonstration,
which almost turned into an experiment,
which made me think I'd never thought that piece of molybdenum wire
could be in the least bit interesting.
And here I am the day after Neil did the experiment still thinking about
it and anything that makes scientists think is really good and
anything that makes us think differently. Yeah.
Brilliant.